[Music]
Ralph breaks the internet was just
released and the internet is buzzing it
was full of Disney Easter eggs you
probably missed stay tuned to find out
the best Easter eggs from the new
wreck-it Ralph movie baby one cool thing
about it looks cool it drives cool her
hair is colored hair is Chloe's me okay
guys if you love all things Disney you
should click that subscribe button now
let's check out all those Disney Easter
eggs from Ralph breaks the Internet
sector eight one one three it wouldn't
be a Disney or Pixar movie without a
reference to classroom eight one one
three this Easter Egg appears in all
their computer animated movies classroom
a one one three is the classroom at the
California Institute of Arts where many
of the founding Pixar animator studied
and they obviously learn some amazing
animation skills Ralph breaks the
internet may not actually be a Pixar
film although it's just as great as all
the others but because Pixar as part of
Disney they still referenced a113
where is it when vanellope goes off to
be a pop up in the land of oh my Disney
she is taken to sector a113 by
stormtroopers looking for a113 might be
one of our favorite Disney traditions
Stanley did you know that Marvel is part
of Disney that's right all those big
Marvel Cinematic Universe movies are
part of the Disney Universe wind
vanellope heads over to oh my Disney in
the new movie you can see several Marvel
references but our favorite Easter Egg
is actually a double Easter Egg in every
MCU movie through 2018 Sam Lee makes a
cameo he's been everything from a bus
driver to a chess player Stan Lee was
the genius behind Marvel Comics well
Ralph breaks the internet might not be a
Marvel movie but a digital version of
San Lee makes an appearance penelope
runs into him when she's escaping from
the stormtroopers ebay goods this is one
of the funniest scenes in Brau freaks
the Internet Ralph and vanellope think
eBay is just a game where you shout out
the highest numbers they don't realize
it's money and they accidentally drive
up the price of the sugar rush steering
wheel to 27001 dollars but there are
some subtle Disney Easter eggs hidden in
the scene three of the items being
auctioned are from other Disney movies
Aladdin's magical lamp is up for big and
so is Rapunzel's frying pan from tangled
there's also a unicorn that looks
suspiciously like Vladimir's unicorn
from tingled
did you catch these sneaky pictures take
me to a website that's super intense and
really nuts
oh my Disney when vanellope goes off to
get more likes for a Ralph's viral
videos Ralph and yes send her to a part
of the internet called oh my Disney we
see a ton of awesome Easter eggs in this
section but did you know that oh my
Disney is a real website oh my Disney
comm is the official Disney site for all
sorts of fun stuff there are official
Disney quizzes which we get to see a
version of in this movie there are
Disney news and Disney forums there's
also all sorts of exclusive content we
think it's pretty smart that Disney
plugs their own website by making it a
major part of their new film there's
everything from your two grew at oh my
Disney we have the sudden urge to take a
bunch of Disney quizzes now Star Wars
memorabilia mister Litwack is the
lovable owner of the arcade and any guy
who owns an arcade for more than 30
years has to be a bit of a nerd don't
you think well if you look closely at
his office you can find out a lot more
about him he's setting up internet on a
super old Mac computer so he's
definitely a little out of touch with
modern times he's got some prescription
pill bottles but he is pretty old and
he's also a Star Wars fan he has to Star
Wars collectible plates on a shelf in
his office one depicts Yoda and the
other has to pakka
and since Disney owns Star Wars that's
another easter egg the Disney Princesses
shirts it's not easy being a princess as
we find out in Ralph's breaks the
Internet they have a tendency to end up
cursed and their thunder gets stolen by
big tough men and they have to look on
fleek all the time but the princesses
and Ralph breaks the internet love
vanilla pees comfy styles they make some
new clothes for themselves and the
shirts are amazing Ariel's mentions
Dingle hoppers and thingamabobs Aurora
says nap Queen and Merida's has a
picture of more do the cursed bear from
brave which other princess shirts did
you love think that's awesome stay tuned
for our favorite Easter aid Kermit the
Frog we think it might take a few
hundred viewings to catch all the Disney
Easter eggs and Ralph breaks the
Internet it was kind of like going to
Disney World
there's so much to see you just can't
take it all in we love seeing all sorts
of
characters in the oh my Disney scene and
there are some classics in there too if
you notice behind the stormtroopers
Kermit the Frog makes an appearance
there's a giant Kermit head that seems
to be showing off The Muppet movie
section of the website and we almost
missed it Mickey Mouse ears it's not a
Disney movie without sneaking in a
reference to the original Disney
characters Mickey Mouse himself may not
have made it into the film but there was
no shortage of Mickey Mouse ears you
know my Disney the princesses are on
stage greeting fans we can see several
of the digitized fans donning Mickey
Mouse ears and one little girl is
wearing a Minnie Mouse polka dot bow we
counted at least six pairs of Mouse ears
those animators sure did try to sneak
that reference by us did you spot any
other Mickey or Minnie references to the
be Ralph Rex the Internet yes since he
is wreck-it Ralph oh yeah but break the
Internet it's like a thing the other
studio one of the best parts of Ralph
breaks the Internet is how Disney has no
problem making fun of itself
the princess scene even points out how
problematic some of the old movies were
like all the curses and kidnappings one
of the funniest jokes was about Meredith
she goes off on some Scottish rant that
no one can understand the princesses
whisper that no one understands her and
she is from the other studio they mean
that Merida is the only Pixar princess
and brave was not one of the more
popular Disney or Pixar movies they make
fun of the whole situation
poor Merida baby Moana there are two
amazing post-credit scenes one has a
small child who is playing the bunny and
kitty cat video game on a tablet the
little girl says she's upset that a
scene from the trailer wasn't in the
movie that's the scene from her game
Ralph comes in and over stuffs the bunny
until it well it's not pretty
did you recognize the little girl Phoebe
Moe is none other than baby Moana this
is some weird alternate universe stuff
that baby Moana exists in two worlds but
she's pretty much the cutest we were
glad to see her make a cameo did you say
for the other awesome post-credit scene
what was your favorite Disney Easter egg
in the movie let us know in the comments
below and those are 10 of the Disney
Easter eggs you might have missed give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to hit that big red subscribe
button for more Disney good
see you later
[Music]